okay this is a very common dog spot  injury that many people have around the  yard fairly easy to remedy the first  thing you want to do is is remove the  debris that's been burned from the dog's  urine and just get a rake and kind of  just dig yourself up here and you see  how nice and easy it comes up and you  can see we're a little bit for a little  grade here so I've got some compost here  from the backyard that we've got and  what I'm going to do is add a handful of  seed into my bucket I have just a little  bit of soil in about a handful of seed  and just mix it up and you should be  able to see plenty of seeds in there and  you start adding it to the hole  establishing a little bit of a of a  grade here now you want to establish  intimate contact between the seed and  soil so the seed can extract water from  the soil so you just get and step down a  little bit and you're all set